and tonight maybe another piece of what
could be a
big postseason puzzle for the blue jays
pitching staff and that is robbie ray
stanton is 18 for 62 with four homers
and 10
rbis the 3-2 pitch fastball anthony's
strike three calls
one two three work for robbie ray in the
top of the first and he punches out a
pair of new york yankees
tonight masahiro tanaka gets his final
tune-up
he will pitch game two of the playoffs
next wednesday here's bloody with one
for three last night
the pitch swinging a line drive through
the middle a base hit into center field
biggio steams around third he'll come in
to score first to third for hernandez
on an rbi single by vladimir guerrero jr
one nothing toronto in the first now
here is goriel
he's at 290 10 homers and 30 rbis
another throw down to first and it gets
away from boyd
oscar will come in to score guerrero's
rounding second
the ball sticks on the dirt and bladdy's
into third
now here's the [ __ ] to gorielle and
it's grounded
to third archela throws to first
so they're loaded with one out for gary
sanchez the catcher hitting 147 but he
does have 10 home runs on the season
here's sanchez and the pitch is not only
high but it gets away from janssen
voight scores and the others runners
move to second and third
the one-two pitch down to the dirt he
chased the slider
to go into the glove big strikeout for
robbie ray
now there's two away and here's clint
frazier who's at 286
eight homers and 26 rbis the 2-2
is hit high in the air out to left field
freezing for a moment guriel on the run
reaches out slides while making the
catch to retire the yankees
so here's guerrero rbi single in the
first inning
hits it hard and down the left field
line
grichik is on his way to third he's
getting the wave
heading home and will score without a
throw on an rbi double by guerrero
that extends the lead joe panic is going
to lead it off it'll be panic
jansen and biggio in the bottom of the
fourth
ground it and grab there by boy nice
play he flips the tanaka covering
for the first down as danny jansen comes
to the plate rifle the double into the
left field
or over the head of the left field at
frazier last time up now he swings and
he rips one to deep left
that one's got a shot it is gone
danny jansen's fifth home run gets out
in a heartbeat
and the blue jays up their lead to 4-1
and an opportunity for grichik to do
some damage
and a hanger is lined into left field a
base hit
tanaka got a ball up britchik made him
pay
biggio into score and it's five to one
two out bases still loaded labor torres
the batter
the 1-1 pitch is a fastball hit in the
air out to right field playable for t
oscar hernandez he squares up he's there
a two-handed squeeze as that retires the
side and the yankees get them bloated
with nobody out and the yankees leave
them loaded
with nobody in the blue jays will stay
in front
5-1 over the new york yankees midway
through the fifth inning
vladimir guerrero junior is coming to
the plate and he's been in the middle of
everything tonight
and a 3-2 pitch bounced on the ground
towards third high hop handled by her
shella he'll just have one play
and that's in his own bag they'll get
the force out on hernandez buchette
comes in to score
it's 6-1 toronto lotus gorilla junior
the hitter
he's two for three
and a base hit into left field grichik
around
third on his way home the throw is not
in time
and it is seven to one for the blue
chase
and now lions on to face shaw
two-two broken bat chip shot into right
field down for a base hit
here comes guerrero he can score guriel
gets the stop sign at third
it's an rbi base hit for travis shaw and
the blue jays have tallied three here in
the sixth inning
and they have opened up an eight to one
lead over new york
so here's jansen he's three for three
and it hit him in the foot well he won't
get his triple but he'll get an easy rbi
and it's nine to one
kevin walked his first time up bounced
to second then singleton scored in the
fourth
applied to right in the fifth and he
swings and he lines the ball into right
field down for a base hit
judge will cut it off in the warning
track and here come the runs
one is in two is in a runner rounding
third and getting the stop sign is
jansen
it's a two run base hit for kevin biggio
toronto is batted around this is the
tenth player bushette started this
with a single to short the ill-1 the
shet swings and drives the ball to the
gap in the left center field hicks on
the run reaches out
and it's off his glove down for a base
hit jansen is in to score
biggio is in to score two run double for
bulbashet
the runs are pouring in danny now with
two hits against masahiro tanaka is
5 for 9 in his career against the yankee
righty
1-1 pitch swung on it belted deep left
field
danny jansen's got another one
it's a four-hit night for danny jansen
a single a double and now two home runs
his sixth of the season makes it 14-1
blue jays and it'll be clint frazier
with two down here in the ninth inning
and the blue jason out away from
reducing their magic number to one
panic slips a bit recovers and gets him
and that's the ball game